je suis en Équateur dans la ville
d'ibara
direction
Mercedes
un village perdu dans la Cordillère des
Andes
3000 mètres au-dessus du niveau de la
mer
là-bas un incroyable gisement dehors a
été découvert il y a 2 ans
[Musique]
perché à flanc de montagne c'est l'une
des plus hautes mines du monde
elle offre aux hommes un ordre d'une
qualité exceptionnelle
oui c'est de l'or
mais elle est illégale
un gramme c'est 50 dollars
et quasiment inaccessible
escalade
le tournage le plus physique que j'ai
jamais fait de ma vie
pour sortir quelques sacs d'or les
mineurs doivent affronter les colères de
la montagne et du ciel
et il va y avoir un éboulement c'est
dangereux
tiens regarde regarde
j'ai un peu peur là on se casse
mais en Équateur les hommes sont prêts à
tout endurer pour gagner quelques
dollars et vous monsieur vous avez quel
âge 65 ans mais si je travaille pas
comment je vais faire pour nourrir ma
famille des conditions de travail
extrêmes et la peur de mourir à chaque
instant
et si tu l'attaques par en haut
qu'est-ce qui se passe il y a tout le
bloc qui tombe et ça t'écrase
[Musique]
caméra abandonnée parce que c'est
dangereux voilà quand cette montagne
s'effondrera il y aura plus d'un mort
c'est pour ça que je veux partir
tout s'est effondré à cause de la pluie
et si ça arrive quand je suis à
l'intérieur
quand on or doit arriver elle arrive
tu vois ça c'est la folie de la mine
on est toujours
à deux doigts de disparaître
[Musique]
au lieu de la civilisation inca
l'équateur a fondé son économie sur les
richesses de son sous-sol
et l'une des plus importantes et lors
pour atteindre la mini légale 3 heures
de piste à travers la montagne
et déjà un problème
bon alors ça c'est la seule route qui va
jusqu'à la Mercedes des buenos aides et
c'est le village qui est juste avant la
mine et plus loin il y a un barrage de
police alors ils peuvent contrôler tout
tout ce qui sort tout ce qui rentre et
en ce moment en fait
comme le gouvernement veut
que les mineurs s'en aille ils empêchent
tout de passer
c'est la police oui après le virage
c'est la police donc là on arrive vers
le barrage on va éteindre la caméra
parce que j'ai une mauvaise expérience
de de contrôle de police
[Musique]
merci de Buenos
dernier village avant la mine
depuis plusieurs semaines c'est
l'embargo décrété par les autorités
matériels pour travailler médicament et
nourriture aucun produit ne peut être
livré à ceux qui vivent ici
[Musique]
et dans l'autre sens c'est pareil les
sacs de terre contenant l'or ne peuvent
être vendus à l'extérieur
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
dollars donc à l'air libre
et pour chaque cas un gardien veille
pour dissuader les voleurs
le gouvernement a décidé de reprendre le
gisement au mineur pour vendre très cher
à une entreprise canadienne
l'exploitation de la mine
[Musique]
et vous vous venez d'où
moi de France de France moi je ne suis
pas d'ici et vous êtes d'où de piment
je suis venue de là-bas
le 13 ça fera deux mois
et quand vous êtes arrivés il y avait
plus de monde
moi je suis arrivé le 13 mars mais là je
vais repartir chez moi
pourquoi vous partez c'est difficile ici
on peut plus je dois dormir par terre à
vous dormez là j'ai mal au dos et je ne
peux pas me permettre de tomber malade
avec le froid la pluie et les averses
oui l'eau passe ici quand il pleut c'est
toutes les nuits je dois me coller au
mur pour ne pas être mouillé
Dounia Rita a décidé de partir
ce n'est pas parce qu'il n'y a plus
d'argent à se faire
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est parce que dans leur cynisme
les autorités ont décidé de priver les
habitants de médecins
il y a encore quelques jours le centre
médical pouvait accueillir les mineurs
et les habitants blessés ou malades
les effectifs hospitaliers ont tous été
transférés dans un autre village
[Musique]
personne
à partir de maintenant un malade devra
faire 3 heures de route pour trouver le
premier médecin 6 pour le premier
hôpital
première averse
elles vont rythmer les sept jours que je
vais passer avec les mineurs
[Musique]
mon contact c'est Périco délégué du tout
nouveau syndicat que les mineurs ont
créé pour défendre leurs intérêts face
aux autorités
c'est lui qui m'a autorisé à filmer ce
qu'il se passait ici
nous sommes les seuls journalistes
acceptées sur cette zone me montrer à
ses côtés va me permettre d'être accepté
par les mineurs
[Musique]
demain il m'emmène à la mine
et a priori ça les fait marrer
[Musique]
6 heures du matin
les camionnettes sont déjà prêtes pour
convoyer les hommes
mais la plupart d'entre eux sont bloqués
au village
ils n'ont même plus de quoi payer le
trajet jusqu'à la mine
[Musique]
au plus fort de l'activité plus de 200
travailleurs par chaque jour
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui se passe pourquoi il y a
si peu de mineurs maintenant
parce que les gens n'ont rien à manger
ici
ils ont épuisé leur ressources car il
n'y a plus moyen de sortir la
marchandise à l'extérieur
on en a jamais eu les moyens
avant on pouvait sortir le matériel en
payant des pots de vin à la police aux
militaire et à d'autres qui faisaient du
profit au détriment de la sueur des
mineurs
c'était une forme d'équilibre exactement
ça se maintenait comme ça ça tenait
comme ça illégal mais accepté accepter
c'est ça c'était une illégalité acceptée
ont bloqué toutes les ressources des
mineurs pour qu'ils ne puisse plus
exercer leur travail il confie ce que la
marchandise à ceux qui descendent il
leur confie ce que tous leurs outils
c'est ça ils sont poursuivis comme des
délinquants il y a beaucoup de gens qui
sont incarcérés il y a environ 300
personnes incarcérées
nous ne faisons de mal à personne nous
ne voulons pas nous ne sommes pas des
délinquants
ce que nous faisons c'est chercher des
moyens pour aider nos familles moi ce
que je propose c'est qu'il nous laisse
sortir avec nos sacs qu'il nous laisse
emmener l'or et nous on disparaît mais
qui nous laisse partir avec le matériel
qui nous a coûté de la sueur
mais madame la gouverneur m'a répondu
dites à vos hommes que le mieux c'est
qu'ils abandonnent leur or et qu'ils
partent mais ça c'est impossible les
gens ne vont pas partir sans leur sac
qui veut laisser sa marchandise ici vous
êtes prêts à partir sans votre
marchandise je crois que non personne
n'est prêt à se faire littéralement
voler le fruit de plusieurs mois de
travail et d'effort
ce qui reste ici vont organiser la
résistance
pour moi c'est l'heure du départ
il n'y a que 3 mineurs qui montent avec
moi
pour économiser les trajets ils
dormiront plusieurs nuits là-haut
après deux heures de piste nous arrivons
à un poste intermédiaire
la plus grosse partie de la
roche-sur-yerre récoltée par les mineurs
est stockés ici
dans ce petit village de fortune les
machettes ne servent pas seulement à
couper le bois
[Musique]
comment ça s'appelle ici
il y a un
viscère la vie
c'est ici qui arrive toute la
marchandise et tout ça c'est bloqué
et tout le monde sait à qui appartient
la marchandise
pas oui oui chaque mineur à son tard
après la vie serre plus de route
il faut marcher pour atteindre la mine
et c'est parti pour 4 heures debout
monter et descente j'ai deux cols à
passer
1500 mètres de dénivelé
premier col
c'est ici que les sacs de roche arrivent
et c'est par des tyroliennes qu'il
descendent de la montagne
donc nous on va aller jusque là-bas
et la mine elle est là
bon on va descendre par là
il reste le plus difficile
atteindre la ville de plastique le
campement dortoir des mineurs
[Musique]
je pensais que
les mineurs nous avait dit qu'il y avait
qu'une heure qu'une heure seulement de
marche
on est à 2h30 j'ai jamais vu ça oui
et tout ça
on n'y arrive pas
[Musique]
après 4 heures de marche nous entrons
dans le camp
[Musique]
nous sommes à 3500 mètres au-dessus du
niveau de la mer
[Musique]
c'est laquelle la meilleure
celle-là enfin les deux sont pareils
une centaine d'hommes qui continue de
travailler en espérant qu'un jour
l'embargo sera levé
ils pourront alors vendre leurs sacs au
prix fort
d'autres aussi mis sur un redémarrage de
l'activité et installe une tyrolienne un
pari sur l'avenir et un investissement à
long terme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
S
[Musique]
merci beaucoup madame
avant il y avait beaucoup beaucoup de
gens oui beaucoup on attendait dehors
pour manger oui il y avait 5 6 cantines
ici
ça cuisinait toute la journée le
déjeuner dîner toute la journée même le
soir tu pouvais manger jusqu'à 10h du
soir les gens arrivaient pour demander
ce qui restait du pain ou n'importe quoi
et qu'est-ce qui s'est passé avec le
gouvernement ils ont mis en prison ce
cache Taylor
ce qui avait de l'or tous ceux qui
venaient pour acheter de la marchandise
ils ont été pris et ce sont eux qui sont
en prison
maintenant il n'y a personne pour
acheter
ce qui achète votre marchandise ont peur
de finir en prison
oui
les policiers saisissent tout en te
pointant avec une arme comme des voleurs
alors que nous on travaille juste pour
extraire de l'or mais ils ne veulent
rien savoir
et les gens pour travailler ici ils ont
dépensé de l'argent
oui certains ont hypothéqué leur maison
d'autres ont vendu leur voiture ou
demander un crédit pour investir ça veut
dire qu'ils ont perdu leur maison leur
voiture tout
il est 16 heures
c'est l'heure de la verse quotidienne
chaque jour l'eau de pluie ramollie un
peu plus la montagne
frankline et miliano et Manolo savent
que leurs amis sont là-haut
et qu'à chaque moment il peut y avoir un
accident
et cette couleur ça veut dire qu'il y a
de l'or
avant un sac comme ça tu le vendais
combien
environ 60 70 80 dollars ça veut dire
que tu es sûr que dans un sac comme ça
il y a plus de 2 g d'or plus 5 grammes
certains disent même 10 g
c'est pour ça que 60 dollars c'est pas
cher
ça c'est de la bonne qualité
un coup de marteau et on voit là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça sent un peu l'humidité mais bon
le matelas est un peu
ça me rappelle la prison
[Applaudissements]
ce que je vais faire c'est que comme il
est 6h et demi en fait mais quelle heure
7h du soir
on va hiverner en fait
voilà
à demain une caméraman qui va se coucher
[Applaudissements]
très froid
troisième jour je vais pouvoir monter à
la mine
et c'est Manolo qui sera mon guide
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est quelle heure
[Musique]
nous sommes à 3500 mètres au-dessus du
niveau de la mer et nous en reste 500 à
monter
la mine est à 4000 mètres
à cette altitude l'air se fait de plus
en plus rare les muscles du corps n'ont
pas assez d'oxygène pour faire des
efforts
à chaque pas le matériel est plus
difficile à porter
[Musique]
sauf pour notre guide depuis deux mois
il fait ce parcours tous les jours
il nous aide à porter des affaires parce
que on n'a pas l'habitude
la Grégory
on est épuisé ça fait 4 heures qu'on
monte
je pensais en une heure
et tous les jours
il est frais lui toi ça va
[Musique]
escalade quoi
je suis en train de me couper un bout de
bois
[Musique]
et là c'est l'endroit où il y a tous les
glissements de terrain donc c'est un peu
chaud à faire vite avant qu'il pleuve
parce que c'est quand il pleut que ça
devient dangereux
[Musique]
impossible de savoir exactement combien
d'hommes travaillent ici
mais une chose est sûre même un embargo
ne pourra les arrêter
ils ont décidé d'amasser les sacs
et d'attendre que les choses se
débloquent
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour atteindre la mine de Manolo il m'a
fallu deux heures trente ça c'est la
marchandise bloquée
tout va bien
comment ça va ça a été la montée
si tu veux
de venir ici
j'ai entendu dire que c'était un bon
plan de venir ici pour travailler dans
les mines donc on est venu au début
c'était super on vendait vraiment bien
les premiers qui sont arrivés là ils se
sont fait beaucoup d'argent moi quand je
suis arrivé j'ai pu en profiter mais
après tous ces dégradés
[Musique]
de l'argent à ma femme
j'ai un enfant qui est en primaire un
autre qui est au collège et j'ai aussi
un petit bébé et là elle n'a plus
d'argent et moi je suis bloqué ici avec
mon ordre
première incursion dans un tunnel
et toujours la même question quand on
entre dans une mine tu es sûr que c'est
renforcé
à chaque fois cette angoisse liée un peu
à la claustrophobie et surtout à la
sécurité
les hommes n'ont qu'un objectif
ronger la montagne
ça c'est joli ça
oui c'est de l'or
[Musique]
ange par le bas
par le sol
ils sont appelés
ceux qui travaillent ici viennent du
Pérou de Colombie et du Venezuela
[Musique]
il y a surtout ceux qui n'ont plus leur
place dans la société équatorienne
ça fait combien de temps que tu es là
février mars avril mais ça fait quatre
mois
ici je suis ouvrier mais j'ai fait des
études supérieures j'ai fait deux ans de
sciences politiques pourquoi tu es venu
ici
c'est difficile de trouver un contrat de
travail en Équateur ah oui après 40 ans
tu n'as plus le droit de travailler dans
la fonction publique
et vous monsieur vous avez quel âge 65
ans
où je peux travailler tranquille et
personne ne me dit rien parce que par
exemple dans une institution publique je
ne pourrais pas travailler parce que je
suis trop vieux si je travaille pas
comment faire je dois faire ça pour
aider ma famille car je n'ai aucune
autre alternative
pour l'instant les autres se partagent
tout l'argent public il se le distribue
entre eux et après c'est nous les
voleurs
je vais entrer une deuxième fois dans le
tunnel
les averses des jours précédents ont
affaibli la structure de protection
pour éviter un effondrement à la
prochaine pluie les mineurs ont décidé
de renforcer la galerie avec des rondins
de bois et des poutres
ce rondin là il faudrait le mettre ici
il manque tout ça il faut plus de 20 cm
et ce que je craignais le plus va
arriver
pendant que les hommes continuent à
creuser la roche sans avoir fini de
renforcer le tunnel la pluie va
redoubler d'intensité
[Musique]
à cet instant je ne sais pas si c'est à
l'intérieur ou à l'extérieur du tunnel
que je suis le plus en sécurité
à l'intérieur l'eau s'infiltre déjà dans
la roche
tandis qu'à l'extérieur la terre meuble
risque à chaque instant de provoquer un
glissement de terrain
ça va faire tomber la vache la terre est
en train de se ramollir et il va y avoir
un éboulement c'est dangereux il y en a
déjà eu un ouais tout est parti en bas
il y avait des gens qui travaillaient on
sait si certains ont été emportés
quand tout est tombé il y avait des gens
qui étaient en train de travailler
c'est dangereux voilà comme il pleut
beaucoup les vieillissement de terrain
c'est c'est
un par semaine donc
on est toujours
à deux doigts de disparaître
chaque tunnel est protégée par une bâche
en plastique
mais avec cette lune ça ne sert plus à
rien
la mine de Manolo est l'une des plus
basses du gisement
il y a un glissement de terrain elle
peut être entièrement chevelu
non c'est dangereux il va y avoir un
glissement de terrain tiens regarde
regarde
on va partir parce que je j'ai un peu
peur là en fait il y a des ça rigole de
juste au-dessus de nous et on sait
jamais et ça c'est
ça peut tomber ouais ça peut tomber
on s'en va
on se casse
on va essayer de descendre en plus ça va
être compliqué
j'ai dû ranger les caméras la descente
sous la pluie va durer trois heures
retour au camp de base 500 mètres plus
bas
c'est la deuxième nuit les gars
on a dû changer de chambre maintenant je
dors avec Greg
[Rires]
il y a de la
on est en Équateur il fait froid
[Musique]
aujourd'hui repos
et c'est pas pour me déplaire
[Musique]
ceux qui ont travaillé la veille vont
récupérer de l'or avec un peu de mercure
c'est le seul moyen pour eux d'avoir
quelques dollars et acheter de quoi
manger
[Musique]
1 g c'est 50 dollars
moi je vais profiter de la journée pour
retourner à Mercedes des Buenos Aires le
syndicat a convoqué tous les mineurs
je suis toujours content
le gouvernement a renforcé l'embargo et
refuse toujours de négocier
les mineurs ont décidé de faire bloc et
d'affronter les autorités
[Musique]
en première ligne Périco l'homme sans
lequel je n'aurais pu accéder à la mine
il va porter les revendications des
travailleurs et tenter de négocier avec
l'État
nous voulons
nous avons tous droit à un emploi stable
et personne ne peut nous retirer le
droit d'être mineur personne ne peut
nous empêcher de réaliser notre rêve
nous voulons pouvoir nourrir notre
famille grâce à notre travail
[Applaudissements]
mais les mineurs ont faim ils pressent
leur représentants et demandent une
solution rapide pour pouvoir vendre leur
sac
si on est là c'est parce qu'on est dans
la galère
je ne sais pas quelle garantit peut nous
donner le syndicat pour que nous
puissions sortir notre marchandise de
Buenos Aires j'ai besoin de savoir il
faut en parler
vous devez nous aider vous les
dirigeants qui êtes ici et notamment
Périco
dites-nous comment et quand on va
pouvoir sortir notre marchandise
je vous en supplie faites quelque chose
[Applaudissements]
la coopérative est là
constituée j'ai les papiers
vous vouliez des papiers ils sont là
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme ça qu'on parle avec force et
vérité
c'est en ayant faim sous le soleil et la
pluie en remontant la pente
à toutes les portes et on supportant les
désagréments que j'ai construit tout ça
tant que je serai là ce sera comme ça
pour tous ou pour personne
[Applaudissements]
le but de Périco faire parler les
mineurs d'une seule voix
mais le chemin est long
les distances sont profondes dans la
société équatorienne
votre organisation est légale et vous
pouvez discuter négocier oui plus
rapidement afin de légaliser la mine
évidemment si on légalise tout ça mon
frère directement il va se créer plus de
100 000 emplois
quand nous sommes arrivés à la plus
belle époque nous étions 15.000
personnes à travailler dans les mines
et vous étiez organisé ou pas non à
l'époque il n'y avait pas d'organisation
chacun travaillait de son côté imaginez
aujourd'hui que nous sommes organisés ce
sera encore mieux
il vous a obligé à vous organiser
on a tous pris la parole
moi personnellement je me suis exprimé
sur le fait qu'ici il y a un racisme
énorme pour le caillot je suis l'une des
personnes qui a combattu cela parce que
je suis noir et nous les Noirs ici on
est une c'est la menthe
[Musique]
cinquième jour
il a plu toute la nuit sur la mine
interdiction de travailler la montagne
est trop dangereuse
[Musique]
je suis mort
malgré le danger il semblerait qu'il
soit nombreux là-haut à vouloir
continuer le travail
allez
je décide de faire une dernière
ascension
le truc c'est que
il a plu toute la journée d'hier
et toute la nuit
donc on peut pas entrer dans les enfin
ils peuvent pas travailler dans les
tunnels
[Musique]
les dégâts des dernières pluies sont
considérables
sous le poids de l'eau une dizaine de
minutes sont détruites
[Musique]
le tournage le plus physique que j'ai
jamais fait de ma vie
[Musique]
plein de mines qui sont recouvertes en
fait super flippant s'il y a quelqu'un
dedans
[Musique]
tout s'est effondré avec la pluie
tout le monde avait quitté son travail
[Musique]
pour les mineurs c'est une journée
perdue ils vont la passer à remettre en
état les tunnels
pourtant certains d'entre eux bravent le
danger et continuent de risquer leur vie
pour quelques grammes d'or
[Musique]
ça se passe bien salut mon ami vous
travaillez à ton avis tu viens d'où de
France mais aussi
aller au Mexique tu fais quoi là je vais
dans les mines à l'intérieur oui je vais
à l'intérieur tu es sérieux ouais tout
c'est sacs c'est à moi mais c'est
dangereux avec la pluie mais celui qui
se mouille pas il gagne rien
c'est long
[Musique]
je peux pas suivre je tète si tu veux en
plus j'ai un peu peur
OK
et là maintenant vous êtes en train de
sortir de la roche c'est ici bonjour
monsieur
tu vois ça c'est la folie de la mine
travailler dans un tunnel et
particulièrement dangereux aujourd'hui
et ces hommes attaquent la roche au
marteau-piqueur
des vibrations sous une montagne fragile
j'aime pas beaucoup c'est dur
approche-toi
j'ai un peu peur là non il y a pas de
problème oui jusqu'à ce qu'il y en ait
un problème quand on meurt doit arriver
elle arrive
oui mais je suis pas sûr que oh c'est
joli ce filon là regarde le filon là
un autre marteau-piqueur il y a deux
tunnels dans cette minute 1 ici et un
là-bas
la vibration ça me fait flipper non
n'est pas peur
ici c'est de la roche de la roche pure
sur 5 mètres et donc il y a pas besoin
de renforcer le plafond
[Musique]
on pose le coffrage à l'entrée
et là où la terre est moins compacte OK
moi je sors en fait là ça va il y a pas
besoin de de protéger que de la roche et
moi j'ai un peu peur c'est à l'entrée
parce que au tout début de la
du tunnel c'est de la c'est de la boue
alors même si ça a été protégé il a
beaucoup plu hier
à cet endroit je vais passer à deux
doigts de l'accident
il te donne un salaire ici je gagne 30
dollars par jour plus la nourriture
c'est pas mal non
parce que je me casse le cul ici non
mais il faut que j'achète un billet
d'avion pour me tirer d'ici
non pas du tout ne prend pas ça
[Musique]
il y a eu juste un éboulement quoi
et ça si ça arrive quand je passe
une minute après ma sortie du tunnel
de Lourdes à l'endroit où je passais
[Musique]
le morceau s'est décroché à cause de la
pluie d'hier
la Terre tombe souvent quand il pleut et
quand tu es dedans
et si l'entrée se bouche
[Applaudissements]
toute la montagne en train de se casser
la gueule
à cause des tyroliennes
petit à petit elles arrachent la terre
et quand il pleut c'est encore pire en
ce moment c'est très très bon quand
cette montagne s'effondrera il y aura
plus d'un mort je te le dis c'est pour
ça que je veux partir
tu vois tout ça et ben ça va tomber dans
pas longtemps
je suis resté 7 jours dans la mine de
Mercedes des Buenos Aires
ce que j'ai rencontré continue d'y
travailler tous les jours
[Musique]
frankline a réussi à déjouer l'embargo
et à vendre quelques sacs il a de quoi
tenir encore quelques mois
[Musique]
ne veut plus prendre de risques il
prévoit d'ouvrir un salon restaurant
dans le camp des mineurs
[Musique]
je n'ai aucune nouvelle d'Estéban le
Venezuela
aucun mineur n'a pu me dire où il était
[Musique]
le blocus est toujours en vigueur le
gouvernement attend le départ des
derniers mineurs pour lancer les
bulldozers à l'assaut du gisement
[Musique]